[Musica]
stasera sono qui e ci tengo
particolarmente perché voglio
raccontarvi scelte di vita chi mi segue
da da anni sa che ne ho fatte diverse di
scelte nella mia vita e mi capita spesso
molto spesso di ricevere mail di giovani
ragazze Sono principalmente ragazze
Magari qualcuna è anche qui nel
pubblico che mi scrivono mi scrivono
bellissime mail e quasi sempre non mi
chiedono la cottura di un arrosto in
forno ma mi chiedono come fare a
cambiare
vita c' ho pensato molto in questi anni
perché in questi 13
anni ho ricevuto così tante mail da
parte vostra in cui mi mi chiedete come
fare a scegliere che ho pensato che il
tema della scelta fosse veramente
qualcosa che mi stava molto vicino e
quando mi hanno chiamato per partecipare
qui ho detto io non posso non andarci io
ho proprio voglia di prendermi quei 15
13 minuti e 50 e raccontarvi Che cosa
vuol dire per me
scegliere perché le scelte non sono
facili o difficili non posso essere io a
dirlo ma credo che nessuno possa
definirle in qualche modo sono scelte e
le scelte comportano sempre qualcosa io
ricordo benissimo il giorno in cui ho
scelto di scegliere ed è il titolo che
ho dato al al mio speech perché è
proprio di quel giorno che voglio
parlarvi Vi faccio una premessa io
arrivo da una famiglia dove si è sempre
celebrata la tavola la tavola intesa
come cibo intesa come vino intesa come
convivialità ma anche la tavola intesa
come luogo dove
attorno si forma una famiglia e attorno
ad una tavola ci si confronta si parla
si si discute si litiga si piange e si
prendono delle decisioni mio padre mi ha
sempre detto che attorno ad una tavola
si fanno delle scelte possono essere
scelte condivise possono essere scelte
di un singolo però sonoo cresciuta con
questo valore della tavola che io ho
sposato davvero in toto
e sono cresciuta con l'idea che la
scelta potesse essere condivisa o no ma
bisognasse farla lo dico perché non è
per anni ho pensato che le scelte fatte
attorno a quel tavolo non fossero le mie
Ma fossero dei miei genitori e mi sono
risposta ero figlia quindi sceglieva
qualcuno per me in realtà quando sono
diventata grande ho capito che io
sceglievo comunque sceglievo di far
scegliere qualcun altro e E questo
capita spesso quando si è piccoli ma in
realtà capita anche quando si è grandi
Vi potrei fare un elenco infinito di
persone adulte mie coetanee anche più
grandi di me che scelgono di non
scegliere e non credo che sia perché sia
una strada più facile credo che sia
proprio una scelta di vita scegliere di
vivere in un determinato
modo vi dicevo prima che io ricordo
benissimo il giorno in cui ho scelto di
scegliere perché era un lunedì mattina
ed era 2009 e io andavo in azienda come
tutte le mattine ma invece che salire al
mio piano dove c'era il mio ufficio Io
non avevo un ufficio una mia scrivania
Scelsi di salire due piani più su due
piani più su C'erano le risorse umane
e e quel giorno senza dirlo a nessuno io
decisi di licenziarmi
avevo 25 anni lavoravo da 2 anni in
azienda avevo studiato giurisprudenza mi
era stato detto che se dopo una laurea
in giurisprudenza il mio il mio futuro
era abbastanza stabilito dopo un master
in comunicazione anche Insomma qualcuno
mi aveva sempre detto che la strada era
abbastanza certa la mia strada Eppure io
volevo fare tutt'altro nella vita
il giorno in cui io ho scelto di
scegliere lo definisco così perché è
stato un giorno in cui io non ho chiesto
a nessuno il permesso di andare due
piani più su è stato un giorno in cui io
mi sono svegliata e non l'avrei mai
immaginato mi sono svegliata quella
mattina e ho deciso che quella non era
più la mia vita e non era più la mia
strada non sapevo assolutamente se fosse
la scelta giusta o la scelta sbagliata e
a questo ci arriveremo
perché perché c'è un tema molto
importante per me che è quello della
scelta giusta e della scelta S stagliata
abbiamo tutti un'immagine in mente
quando pensiamo alla scelta Pensiamo ad
una persona a volte si vede di spalle
due strade la strada di sinistra la
strada di destra a me mette ansia solo
pensarci di avere una strada a sinistra
una strada a destra e pensare che se
scelgo quella Magari sbaglio Dovevo
andare di là in realtà la cosa che quasi
nessuno fa e che io ho imparato a fare
negli anni è non concentrarmi sulla
strada di sinistra o sulla strada di
destra perché chi può dirlo Qual è la
scelta giusta io stessa come posso
sapere prima di farla una scelta se può
essere quella giusta o quella sbagliata
Se non la vivi una cosa se non la
percorri una strada come fai a sapere se
è quella che ti porta dove vuoi
andare e allora ho pensato Ma su cosa mi
devo
concentrare e ho pensato che la cosa più
importante fosse concentrarsi sui piedi
e questa è una cosa che caratterizza la
mia vita veramente da negli ultimi 10
anni mi aiuta moltissimo a scegliere io
non guardo più i pro e i contro di un
lato i pro e contro dell'altro mi
concentro sui miei piedi e
particolarmente sul movimento dei miei
piedi sono piedi che normalmente sono
immobili sono piedi che tremano sono
piedi che hanno paura e la paura negli
anni ho imparato che bisogna farsela
amica ma in realtà c'è un momento Esatto
in cui una persona sceglie di scegliere
ed è il momento in cui fa questa cosa
qua che è un passo cioè c'è una frase
bellissima qui sono molto legata che
dice che il primo passo non ti porta
dove vuoi andare ma ti sposta da dove
sei Ed è esattamente quella cosa lì è
una cosa che ci ho messo degli anni a
capire nel 2009 quando andai appunto
alle risorse umane Non avevo idea di Di
dove sarei andata io ricordo di essermi
sentita leggera quando sono uscita da lì
e un mese dopo quando un mese dopo il
giorno delle dimissioni quando ho preso
il treno che da Rogoredo mi portava a
Milano Garibaldi non lo dimenticherò mai
sono passati 14 anni me lo ricordo come
se fosse ieri ho pianto tutte le mie
lacrime però alla fine mi sono sentita
estremamente leggera e la mattina dopo
io avrei potuto dormire fino alle 11:00
avrei potuto fare tutt'altro E invece ho
lasciato la
sveglia delle mie mattine in ufficio
e ho ricominciato a lavorare dalla
mattina dopo in modo diverso ho iniziato
a studiare cucina mi sono messa a fare
un corso di fotografia serale ho
iniziato a riempire quel tempo perché
sapevo che nel momento in cui non hai
qualcuno che ti dice cosa fare devi
essere tu a farlo ed è anche abbastanza
difficile così giovani però sapevo che
quella sarebbe stata la scelta della mia
vita e non sapevo ancora se fosse la
scelta giusta o la scelta sbagliata
sapevo che era sicuramente quella più
adatta a me non mi sono chiesta mille
volte che cosa mi rendesse felice in
quegli anni e c'erano un sacco di cose
soprattutto in azienda c'erano i
colleghi c'era la la quotidianità lo
stare insieme il lavoro di team Poi un
giorno mi sono guardata allo specchio e
mi sono detta Ma c'è qualcosa che non ti
rende felice c'è qualcosa che non hai
più voglia di fare e la e la risposta
era assolutamente Chiara e io io volevo
lavorare da sola Io volevo decidere io
cosa fare io non volevo seguire un
percorso stabilito da altri io volevo
seguire un percorso mio un percorso
fatto di passioni eppure ero circondata
di persone che mi dicevano
quotidianamente non hai fatto la scuola
alberghiera e non puoi cucinare non hai
fatto la scuola di giornalismo non hai
studiato scienze della comunicazione non
puoi scrivere Pensate che io avevo un
sogno da bambina che era quello di
diventare giornalista e cucinare Io in
realtà volevo diventare come la fallace
avevo un sogno piccolo era il sogno
della mia vita Eppure se ci penso oggi e
ci ho pensato tanto in questi giorni
prima di venire qui che mi sono detta Ma
di di quali scelte posso parlare ne ho
fatte tante però questa forse è quella
che veramente ha segnato di più la mia
vita prima del 2014 l'anno in cui ho
avuto mia figlia bianca ed è stata
un'altra scelta molto importante però
questa mi avvicina moltissimo a tutte le
persone che mi scrivono quotidianamente
perché io mi rendo conto quanto
difficile sia trovarsi davanti a un
bivio e tutti mi scrivono la stessa cosa
Ho paura E allora sulla paura vi dico
un'altra cosa che ho imparato in questi
anni in questi ultimi 13 anni che in
realtà la paura veramente bisogna
farsela amica perché c'è un istante
preciso in cui dovete imparare ad avere
la
sensibilità di riconoscere che la paura
diventa con questo passo Qui è sempre il
passo che vi dicevo prima diventa
coraggio è un unico passo
sembra una cosa semplicissima Eppure
quando si è immobili e si è Fermi è
difficilissimo farlo quel passo perché
non è un passo che ti porta da nessuna
parte come vi dicevo prima è un passo
che ti sposta da dove sei Ma il fatto
solamente di farlo questo passo ti sta
già portando dove vuoi andare che poi
sia destra
sinistra permettetevi il lusso di sapere
di dirvi tutti i giorni che non esiste
scelta giusta o scelta sbagliata perché
le scelte e le strade cambiano Nella
vita succedono un sacco di cose si può
tornare indietro si può andare avanti si
può cambiare strada si può prendere una
scorciatoia e poi magari trovarsi sulla
strada più lunga succedono tantissime
cose nel percorso lavorativo e di vita
di una
persona e quindi non essendoci strade
giuste o strade sbagliate l'unica cosa
su cui potete concentrarvi è quel
momento Esatto in cui la paura che
vi fa rimanere fermi immobili diventa
coraggio facendo Semplicemente
così